und wir kommen jetzt zu unserem nächsten
fall und zeigen ihnen gleich bilder die
mich persönlich wirklich an meine
recherchen in syrien oder im irak
erinnert haben nämlich riesige
trümmerfelder ausschuss glas und blech
und das alles mitten im wohngebiet in
deutschland in nrw denn hier haben
geldautomaten sprenger zugeschlagen wie
da und zwar an unfassbaren vier tatorten
in nur einer einzigen nacht alexa live
berichtet
es sind bilder wie aus einem
kriegsgebiet trümmer so weit das auge
reicht überall liegen schutt und geröll
um eine gewaltige explosion hat hier
alles zerstört die geldautomaten mafia
hat wieder zugeschlagen diesmal hat ihre
bombe sogar die mauern der bankfiliale
zerfetzt nur dass sparkassen logo in den
trümmern deutet darauf hin dass hier
einmal ein haus stand selbst 40 meter
entfernt liegen noch glassplitter auf
der straße die kraft der bombe war
gewaltig zwei detonationen ließen gegen
2 uhr dem boden in schalksmühle beben
von der sparkassen filiale ist nichts
mehr übrig geblieben weite teile des
gebäudes sind eingestürzt als die
polizei eintraf fand sie nur noch ein
trümmerfeld vor es ist als hätte die
geldautomaten mafia in dieser nacht zum
mittwoch den banken den krieg erklärt
und zum großangriff geblasen an
insgesamt vier tatorten schlagen sie
innerhalb weniger stunden zu sie bomben
und springen in schalksmühle oberhausen
jüchen engelskirchen in oberhausen wird
die deutsche bank getroffen auch hier
trümmerschutt chaos die zerstörung durch
die explosion ist gewaltig die komplette
filiale wurde zerstört auch die scheiben
eines benachbarten geschäftes ging zu
bruch auch für die anwohner war es eine
unruhige nacht sie mussten ihre
wohnungen verlassen
auffällig vorgehen und täterbeschreibung
ähnelt dem anschlag von schalksmühle
heute nacht gegen 31 ist ein geldautomat
in der schmachtendorfer straße in
oberhausen gesprengt worden zeugen
hatten der polizei einen lauten knall
gemeldet sie haben auch drei personen
beobachtet die vom tatort geflüchtet
sind mit einem silbernen audi a 6 die
front in diesem krieg der automaten
springer verläuft an der holländisch
deutschen grenze die täter kommen in der
nacht aus den niederlanden nach
nordrhein-westfalen schlagen hierzu und
verschwinden wieder im ausland das
lagebild des bka zeigt nirgendwo sonst
knallt es so häufig wie in nrw und die
täter werden immer brutaler
die polizei spricht mittlerweile von
sprengungen 3.0 denn die täter setzten
bei ihren angriffen nicht mehr auf gas
mischungen sondern wie terroristen auf
sprengstoff also während wir früher in
den letzten jahren sehr sehr häufig mit
sprengungen zu tun hatten die mit
seitens der täter mit gas luft gemisch
herbeigeführt wurden haben wir so seit
dem letzten jahr vermehrt feststellen
müssen dass die täter fest sprengstoffe
einsetzen das macht die sache deutlich
gefährlicher als sie ohnehin schon war
wie gefährlich zeigt sich wenige tage
zuvor in dinslaken wieder bilder wie
nach einem bombenangriff die fassade
gesprengt überall glassplitter
diesmal ist sogar ein sprengstoff
spezialist mit speziellen schutzanzug
und eine entschärfung slaughter im
einsatz mitten im wohngebiet eine
unwirkliche szene
der grund für den einsatz als die ersten
beamten eintreffen steckt in dem
automaten noch eine extrem gefährliche
sprengladung fest der bereich um den
explosionsort wohl daraufhin weiträumig
abgesperrt die umliegenden häuser
evakuiert die feuerwehr ist mit einem
großaufgebot hier ein roboter hat diesen
gegenstand sich angeschaut es wurde dann
ein weiteres spezialfahrzeug
nachgefordert in gefährlicher
millimeterarbeit gelingt es den
polizisten den sprengsatz in das
spezialfahrzeug zu bugsieren auf einem
feld wird er schließlich in die luft
gejagt
ortswechsel leichlingen auf den ersten
blick war es eine geldautomaten
sprengungen wie sie inzwischen jede
nacht verübt werden zwei detonationen um
238 in der nacht zertrümmerten das foyer
einer bankfiliale drei täter flüchteten
mit einem dunklen sportwagen aber
diesmal schlagen die täter ausgerechnet
in der heimatstadt von nrw-innenminister
herbert reul zu da lässt man sich nicht
vom wohnsitz von innenminister oder
ähnlichen personen von irritieren
gesprengt wird halt in jeder kommune in
nordrhein westfalen das ist leider so
bevorzugt natürlich da wo die autobahnen
autobahnanbindung sehr gut sind weil das
das fluchtverhalten ja extrem
unterstützt und die angriffe der
vergangenen nächte beweisen noch immer
sind viel zu viele automaten sprenger
auf freiem fuß und wahrscheinlich plant
sie in diesen minuten bereits den
nächsten anschlag
ja man muss sich das noch mal vorstellen
vier sprengungen allein in einer nacht
und die täter alle auf der flucht wenn
sie hinweise haben zu den sprengungen
und den tätern dann wenden sie sich zum
beispiel an das lka in nordrhein
westfalen unter 0211 93 90